you may recognize this building it's the
Engineering and Applied Sciences
Building just behind the science center
as an engineer when I look at this photo
I see two types of materials all the
engineering structures are made with
hardwa terials such as metals glass
concrete but if you look at nature
plants and animals including humans are
mostly made with soft materials if you
look inside animals or plants we can
find many soft biological materials that
contain mostly water is there an
engineering material that is similar to
these biological materials they are
called hydrogels hydrogens are composed
of water and a polymer network hydrogels
are not new to us one example is jell-o
jell-o is soft similar to natural
biological materials but the problem is
that if you are thinking about
engineering applications many hydrogels
including cello and not suitable they're
so fragile even a spoon can break them
they are not strong or tough enough to
bear any load researchers have been
trying to make strong and tough
hydrogels for many years but in our
group we were able to solve this problem
we develop a hydrogel that is
dramatically different it's much
stronger and tougher than any of the
hydrogels it can be made into very thin
sheets it is extremely stretchable and
hard to break our design principle
includes adding too fragile hydrogels to
improve the mechanical properties if you
look at the molecular structure it
contains single polymer networks but by
binding these two we created a hybrid
hydrogel that we call tough hydrogel
tough hydrogels look similar to its
parent materials but it's much stronger
and tougher they're easy to make and
they are also inexpensive the synthesis
of the hydrogel include adding the
powders of the parent materials to a
large quantity of border there then mix
with the crosslinking agents and poured
it into a mole to set when it is said we
can remove it in solid form these
hydrogels contain more than ninety
percent water they also can be made into
very large pieces as we develop this
extremely tough hydrogel that is easy to
make and inexpensive I ask but can we do
with this material let's look at the
molecular structure of these hydrogels
high officials are primarily composed of
water molecules and the polymer network
just give the structural support but we
have done is that we are made water
tough water has amazing properties for
example what we can absorb a large
amount of heat water can conduct ions
and hydrogels retain all these
properties let's consider the ability of
absorbing heat from a fire our
hypothesis was that when the hydrogel is
exposed to a fire instead of catching
fire it can absorb a huge amount of heat
and retard the fire this is a comparison
of firefighters fabric versus our
hydrogels as you can see it's a huge
problem in firefighting that current
fire retarding fabrics do not give
enough protection at hot flames in
contrast our materials have a great
potential to make a parallel to protect
people's lives from burn injuries in
case of a fire this can be made into a
big blanket that
you can wrap around or even a jacket
that you can bear and escape safely
because this hydrogel contained more
than ninety percent border it can be
made very inexpensive so anyone can have
it so in future I envision that the
technology with soft materials is so
developed not only can they be used in
fire protection but we can think of many
other applications because stuff
hydrogels are similar to natural tissues
one day it can be used for cartilage
replacement these hydrogels can be used
as artificial muscles tough hydrogels
can be made into bearable electronics
that are compatible with human body we
can think of many other applications
with this amazing material and possibly
help to solve the long-standing
engineering problems in nervous thank
you